[Musik]
was ist das denn die kamera und die
läuft ja schon krass ey was genau alles
bekommen war mein video
ich hab geraten ruft man wohl auch nicht
hast du das gefühl ich wäre mischung
kommt wenn ich glück gehabt wenn ich
morgen wieder richtig gesund wenn ich
pech habe bin ich noch mehr kommen ihr
kennt das wahrscheinlich man denkt der
hals kratzt
also es ist halt ganz minimal ich würd
mal sagen ich bin leicht angeschlagen
auf jeden fall habe ich mir dennoch
nicht nehmen das nun für euch heute eine
video aufzunehmen
normalerweise bin ich gar nicht der fan
von solchen videos wo man einfach jahren
pc sitzt und irgendwas macht und dann
sagt auch dass ich cool sowie action
scheiße weil da steckt 0-lauf mann
hinter und das ist sich mein content zu
aber ich habe letztens ein video auf
youtube gesehen und dann habe ich
irgendwie drauf geklickt so dastand
irgendwas von wenn du das siehst du
farbenblind
und der typ hatte halt wirklich so auch
so es wird halt darum dass man so zahlen
sehen muss in so mustern und in so
verschiedenen farben und ich hab
manchmal einfach keine zahl gesehen wo
ich mir dachte hey als wenn du das jetzt
nicht siehst du ich habe es einfach
nicht gesehen und genau deswegen mache
ich jetzt das video mit euch zusammen
ich spiele dieses spiel jetzt selber mal
kurz also dies das ist so ein test wisst
ihr und dann gucke ich mal ob ich das
wirklich nicht sehe also vieles habe ich
erkannt 90 prozent habe ich erkannt aber
ich würde sagen so sieben bis acht
prozent auch nichts neues können sind
ich würde mal sagen so 92 prozent habe
ich erkannt 18 ich und zwar bin ich auf
der seite endpunkt komm ich will gar
nicht lange lagern wenn es euch gefällt
dann lasst man auch nach oben da und
schreibt auf jeden fall mal unten in den
kommentaren weil welcher zahlen oder bei
welchem bild ihr schwierigkeiten hatte
ja jetzt optionen kann man jetzt
startest machen hier so ok also hat er
das konzept verstanden hier wieder
einmal eine zahl eingeblendet man muss
jetzt einfach sagen was es für die zahl
ist ich sag jetzt mal das ist nur zwei
das kann ich ganz klar sehen dass hier
ist eine 5 das hier ist eine 2 das hier
ist eine 1 das hier ist eine 8
das hier ist eine 1 dass jetzt eine 7
das hier ist eine 5 das war schon schwer
dass jetzt auch mit sieben ich finde es
wird irgendwie immer schwerer so und
hier denke ich mir jetzt gerade da ist
doch nix oder willst deine zahl so das
habe ich letztes mal auch gedacht da ist
einfach keine zahl sieht ja irgendwer
von euch eine zahl also ich sehe da
definitiv keine das könnte ganz
vielleicht eine acht sein
aber ich glaub nicht so schreibt doch
bitte jetzt meine kommentare was ist das
für eine zahl
ich würde jetzt einfach mal sagen da ist
gar nichts das ist jetzt wieder eine 5
das ist neu
das ist ne eins das ist eine 5 und hier
bin ich jetzt schon wieder so
keine ahnung ich weiß es nicht
eventuelle zwei so wenn ich von weiter
weg gruppe glaube ich ist es nur zwei
und wenn ich von hier gucke sehe ich
einfach gar nichts wartet mal kurz ich
hab eine idee
[Musik]
man sich umguckt falsch rum ich habe
keine ahnung ich würde es einfach mal
sagen ist eine 2
schippmann alle denken jetzt
wahrscheinlich von mir boris sehr blöd
der sieht das nicht könnte eine 4 sein
ich komme gerade mächtig druck klar das
ist einfach jetzt meine 4
das ist eine 14 06 keine ahnung ich weiß
es nicht
was ist denn das für ein test das ist so
wie die gleiche scheiße
das kommt nicht eben ich sehen warum
soll ich sagen jetzt erkennen gar nichts
ich bin mir da fing das ist nur 2 die
wollen mich verarschen könnt ihr gerade
was sehen
da sind einfach punkte ganz eventuell
könne das nur eins sein
das ist nur eins oder so wer hier
betrachtet so das geht ganz leicht das
ist eine eins das ist ne 2 das sehe ich
ganz ganz eng auch was ist das denn
leute ich sehe es einfach ein spaß am
sex nur mit kanadischen aurora mit den
shake den euro nie liebte test
conditions das in die kälte hält
aber ich verstehe trotzdem ich warum ich
manchmal einfach nicht erkannt habe ich
wollte immer kurz sagen ich bin glaube
ich farbenblind also so einige farben
kann ich erkennen lkw's wirklich ging
das euch jetzt genau so dass ihr so ein
paar sachen einfach nicht erkannt
vielleicht war auch einfach nichts
laufen aber ich glaub schon jahr wollte
was soll ich dazu noch sagen also
sondern direkt im video wird natürlich
nicht noch mal geben das ist mir einfach
zu aufwendig und zu langweilig so das
war auf jeden fall jetzt ein cooler test
wenn doch mal wenn ihr noch so einen
coolen test habt oder irgendwas richtig
krass könnte mir aus gerne schicken dann
macht das vielleicht noch mal aber diese
anderen projekten scheiße finde ich
einfach mega langweilt außer natürlich
musical die da bin ich der king bin ich
nicht ich weiß nicht warum könnt ihr
euch freuen auf neues musical video von
mir lass nach oben laufen gefahr checkt
snap chat und instagram ab wir sehen uns
dann am morgen gegen morgen
morgen des montag wieder das wort wieder
rein ich wünsche noch einen angenehmen
sonntag und beim eine linse getroffen